Is melatonin a recommended cancer hormone supplement for all or certain cancers?
so melatonin and so normally if you took melatonin
To help you sleep you take three milligrams maybe six milligrams, but typically
melatonin supplements come in a three milligram dose to help you fall asleep
The melatonin for cancer is taken at a 20 milligram to 200 milligram dose, so it's high dose melatonin
Well melatonin at normal dose actually has some antioxidant properties, but melatonin above 20 milligrams
has an oxidative property, so it's oxidative
so again
if you're we talked a little bit about that the difference with pro oxidative and an antioxidant who we started this conversation
so if
That's still kind of foggy in your eyes go to the article on the website called hearticine
oxidative stress to kill cancer to start typing in hearticine and it'll pop up the first blog post read that watch videos that will help
But the question is is it good for all cancers or just certain cancers?
Well melatonin at high dose is not is not is can be used on all cancers, so there isn't any cancer that you say no
Don't use melatonin high dose
That I know of
So it can be used on all cancers now
Why don't I tell everybody to do it because I do just with cheek swab does because
There's a hundred different supplements that are good for all cancers and you can't take all of them you'd be taking 350 supplements a day
So it's just a matter of what tests, but if you again feel glad to I really feel like I should take melatonin too
You just want to make sure you're taking at least 20 milligrams and
There's there's different brands like allergy research has one that's a 20 milligram
Sub in one pill so you're not taking a three milligrams supplement have it take seven of them so